right 15 to 25 as a fraction in simplest
form so 15 to 25 is just a ratio and we
can write it so they've given us 15 to
25 and you could write this ratio as a
fraction as 15 over 25 and if we want to
put this in simplest form we just have
to think about what is the largest
number that divides into both 15 and 25
or what is their greatest common factor
when you just eyeball it you say well 5
goes into both of them and I'm pretty
sure that's the largest number that
divides into boat so let's divide both
by 5 and if there is a larger number
then we might be able to see it once we
simplify it a little bit more so let's
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 5 and see what we get so now we get
15 divided by 5 is equal to 3 and 25
divided by 5 is equal to 5 and now we
have it being 3/5 and 3 and 5 don't
share any common factors greater than 1
so it is in simplest form so we've done
what they asked we've written it as a
fraction in simplest form and we could
also write this if we want to write it
in this type of notation as 3 to 5